when I was walking across Antarctica my
solo crossing the first day I started
crying man I started crying because I
could barely pull my sled I had a
thousand miles to go and I couldn't even
like really cross the first quarter mile
and when you crying it's minus 30 minus
40 degrees outside Antarctica doesn't
take it easy on you just freezes the
tears to your face you feel like a real
pathetic loser
calling no Brady what came with the show
great to be here with You Chris thanks
for having me how connected did you feel
to the discovery of shackleton's ship
endurance when they found it a few
months ago oh man it was uh that was
like uh it's like a kid on Christmas
waking up to that news I remember I got
the New York Times alert and then my
phone started blowing up because so many
people know how
um you know fondly I think of uh
Antarctica but specifically Shackleton
Shackleton has been
um a hero among heroes in my mind and
Consciousness
um I you know the endurance is his story
of that survival is one of my all-time
favorite books I've read you know like
obscure texts of his journals and things
like that so uh I honestly I will say
this though I'm not generally a huge
skeptic but when they said they were
going on this expedition to find that I
was like how could they possibly find
they're like how are they gonna find
this you know like I've I've wrote a
book across Drake Passage I've been in
these Waters I've been in there and I'm
like I'm like no but honestly I was
happy to be proven wrong because it was
unbelievable to see those photos
um and and how preserved the boat was I
mean oh my gosh have you got any idea
how they actually managed to find it
because young toxic is pretty big
presumably the GPS coordinates that they
had from whatever it was 1914 1915 or
something and they departed they
wouldn't have been particularly
sophisticated so have you got any idea
how they knew where to look honestly
that that is the part that I I should
probably look deeper into it because I'm
fascinated to know the answer to that
question
um I have no idea particularly because
uh the Weddell sea um and in that
section over there I mean they were on
sea ice and it melted and it Shunk and
you I mean I've literally been in a
rowboat in these Waters with 40-foot
swells and so I've been bashed around
just in the course of a couple of weeks
and you know 100 years you think it's
going to move around at the bottom of
the ocean
um and I think even they were from the
reports I read pretty uh surprised to
see I mean one thing they found it but
how well preserved it was like there
it's just the water is so cold that
there's not as many sort of natural
predators and things that you would have
in a warmer environment of corals and
Barnacles and things that um would
normally kind of Decay so like it was
like practically like Frozen in time I
mean it's wild dude it's so good I given
the fact that you've spent so much time
in the Antarctic did it give you a
different sort of appreciation for what
Shackleton and those guys did was there
any extra insights you know if you're
reading Alfred lansing's book which is
my favorite uh description of the the
Shackleton Crossing uh you know you read
that and it's such an intense story
learning about how they were first they
had to kill the dogs and then they're
having to look for seals and then they
leave some of the men behind and they
strap all of the ballast that they can
to one of the ships but you've you've
got to see this yourself first hand did
that add some richness to the story
um I mean completely I will say this I
uh you know I I am proud of my uh solo
Crossing of Antarctica and the various
Expeditions uh been in Antarctica four
times and several Expeditions down there
but you know walking across solo
um Poland you know what I was doing is I
was trying to become the first person
history to cross Antarctica solo
um unsupported which means no resupplies
of food or fuel along the way so taking
all your gear with you and then man
hauling
um which is also what shackle Tim and
them were doing but no no no kites like
no no Motors nothing propelling you just
kind of mono imano kind of in the most
primitive form but I will say I you know
54 days alone I made it across obviously
proud of that whatever there was not a
day that went by in fact there wasn't
often many hours that went by where I
was laughing I'd be like but man you got
GPS out here you got Gore-Tex you've got
like these boots that are molded to your
feet and I would think about Shackleton
and those guys and be like just to get
to Antarctica they had to like take a
year to sail a boat down there and then
they're like oh it's winter so we better
sit here for six months on the sea ice
in the you know in the hull of our ship
basically because it's so cold outside
with like oil lamps and then when
they're walking around you know seal
skin and pelts and things like that
almost I was like man like there's just
a different breed of human 100 plus
years ago and so like I said mostly what
all I have is is I can't even put it
into words the level of gratitude
respect and just like badassery that
those guys were um having experienced
the life and death intense Stakes of
Antarctica but still through a lens of
like well I've seen satellite images of
where I'm going and I do have a story
this is like a five-star experience of
Antarctica totally totally totally no
it's it's incredible and it's incredible
the courage that those guys had to
literally go explore things you know uh
we can't really do this anymore I
suppose space is this next Frontier for
that but on our planet it's pretty hard
to just be like Oh I'm taking a boat
here I don't know I might be back in a
few years don't worry about me you know
it's I mean that's like Adventure at its
truest truest purest form
given the fact that shackleton's one of
the heroes of yours and you've done a
bunch of high mountain Crossings within
short periods of time and stuff like
that how much of a freak is Nim's
perjure
yeah dude Nims is a an impressive guy in
a lot of ways no doubt about it I've uh
I've been fortunate to be in the
mountains with him um on some bigger
Expeditions I was on K2 in the winter in
2021
um and then also on Everest uh my second
time on Everest uh he was guiding over
there and our camps were nearby each
other
um and so uh yeah we spent a lot of time
together not only uh up on the mountains
but also having some fun in base camp
and throwing back some beers
um yeah I mean look his record uh what
he did with 14 Peaks uh in the film is
amazing
um was is really is really special and
more and more even more importantly or
certainly as equally as importantly as
the team he surrounded himself with um
are incredible I mean Nims is an
incredible climber
um but guys like mingma David Sherpa uh
mingmin Tenzing I mean these guys are
just also just incredible world world
class and I'm so happy
um you know he's been his Spotlight is
shining so brightly and it's it's
wonderful particularly for the country
of Nepal you know I've
um been been in the Himalayas plenty and
the a lot if not all Expeditions and the
Himalayas basically quite literally
right on the back of the sherpa
communities and it's been far too long
that it's been like that and those
communities haven't gotten their shine
and so for him to have uh the impact
that he's having and be able to uplift
those voices and now for these Nepalese
guys who in my opinion are are the best
climbers in the world to not be working
for other people or Western climbers or
Europeans to be like hey like we're
doing our own badass records um look at
us uh it's amazing and so yeah he's
impressive and his whole team and those
guys um grateful to know those guys
because they're really special special
humans in so many ways dude he was
telling me about how he used to run to
school every single night and then he'd
run home and train in the gym and he'd
sleep for a couple of hours and then get
up so all of that stuff like the
physical stuff's pretty impressive the
most impressive thing that I think is
his ability to drink like the fact that
he did basically a heavy night in
between that 3 Peaks within the space of
48 hours or something is he's a wild man
that's for sure but you know it's like
you know you see people high performing
in all sorts of different ways you know
I've learned this over time and been
around lots of world record holders
Olympians but also billionaires and
entrepreneurs and whatever and and
you're like yeah the only way you get to
the top of that is like yes you're good
at the thing that you're good at but
you're also usually just a wild human
being in a lot of different
eccentricities
um that makes it that way so uh he
certainly has that in Spades do you know
the be a mile have you heard of this the
Beer Mile yes I'm familiar with this
yeah yeah so it's a record people do
four laps of a 400 meter track and they
have to down a pint of beer at the start
of each lap and one of my friends in the
UK for a while held the record he held
the world record for the BMI nice and I
feel like that's the next stage for
endurance racing that it's it's how hard
you can go the night before it's not
just about climbing Everest or whatever
like that's been done it's like the 14
deaths
well I'm curious what was your buddy's
uh what was his time uh and it was like
four something obviously yeah so I think
it was like a 445 maybe
um but you'll see the way that they do
it when they come back and they grab the
drink they're already speed walking
along right and then the pace because
it's a you have to do it out of a can
too right it's a can of beer isn't that
right not sure I think the rules are a
can of beer which I was always like that
just as you know it's just harder to
chug out of the can like I wonder if
you're allowed to shotgun it take it
from the top shotgun it and just go that
would help that would help that might be
classed as a performance enhancer I'm
not sure but so going back to what it is
that you're doing at the moment and this
idea of sort of taking hold of life I
think and doing extreme things that make
you feel like you're alive there's this
quote from Henry David Thoreau that says
the massive men lead lives of quiet
desperation what's that mean to you
yeah you know I I opened the book with
that quote for a reason
um which is
unfortunately I think in our modern
society people a lot of people are are
kind of stuck and and I take it a little
bit further which is you know I kind of
think of Life uh and experience of Life
on this scale of one to ten so one being
kind of our lowest low moment so we know
what that's like heartbreak you know I
was when I was younger I was burned in a
fire I was told I would never walk again
normally you know I you know adversity
you know pulling a sled across
Antarctica you're going to hit a lot of
uh one moment Shackleton and his team
man they had some ones trying to survive
and get out of the mess that they found
themselves in right we know what ones
are we try to avoid them and at tens we
also know what tens are right like tens
are you know uh falling in love having a
massive achievement selling your company
having amazing sex uh yeah I don't know
what a skiing perfect powder you know
whatever whatever that is for you right
we know these tens we want the teds tens
are amazing who wouldn't want those tens
but I've come to realize
that every time
um that I experience a 10 it's not in
spite of my ones but it's because of my
ones every time I've gone to these Peak
moments it's actually because I've been
willing to risk or willing to take on
the possibility of this low downside
moment however when you that the road
quote the mass of manly lives of quiet
desperation
um you know apply that to modern terms
or this thinking is I find that most
people are kind of stuck in what I call
the zone of comfortable complacency
between four and six like just kind of
like it's fine you know I have this job
I don't love it I don't hate it I go
every day I show up like five five five
five five or been in a relationship for
a while like it's not toxic it's not
abusive it's not like horrible but I'm
just kind of cohabitating and it's just
like fine five five five five and I'm
like why are so many people stuck there
or or is thorough you know 100 plus
years ago said this this quiet
desperation what is that and I think it
actually comes from people trying to
hedge so much against a avoiding this
discomfort or avoiding this pain or
avoiding taking any risk it's just
easier again particularly in a modern
society where you have a phone where you
can just order food and look at your
social media and binge out on Netflix
and get that dopamine hit here there you
know up up and again it's like okay so
but if you take if you're hedging so
hard against those ones
what I found is you actually also take
the sevens eights the nines the tens off
of the table and so I opened the book
there not as a saying well let me just
be depressing we all live these lives of
quiet desperation sorry your [ __ ] out of
luck it's actually to say wake up wake
up like you don't have to be like this
you don't and I open I open the book
with a story about meeting an 80 year
old guy who was a billionaire who pulled
me aside and said
I've made more money than you can
possibly imagine
but he actually in his own way sure in a
nicer apartment or on his private jet or
whatever than the rest of us he even
said to me I missed it man I'm 80 and I
just I just kept doing what other people
wanted me to do and I'm 80 and I don't
have time to go back and Summit my
actual Mount Everest the life that I
wanted to live full of purpose and
desire because even him at the highest
peak Arc of quote unquote success was
vulnerably sharing with me of saying hey
I kind of missed the point and so this
book in a lot of ways is a call to
action to wake people up to shake them
out of this
um you know that this uh this life of
quiet desperation and ultimately as as
the Thoreau quote is often misquoted
people say and die with your song Still
inside of them that's actually Thoreau
never said that but most people think he
did is to sing that song to figure out
what what you're passionate about dive
into that deep fulfillment and the
12-hour walk is a one day prescription
and an invitation to invest one day conk
your mind and unlock your best life and
I'm sure we'll talk more about exactly
what that means
um but I'm passionate about spreading
that message and I know a lot of the
conversations you have with the crazy
incredible people on the show
um feel very similarly through their own
lenses there's an idea that I learned
about last week called the region beta
Paradox so imagine that you have a rule
you always walk whenever you're
traveling a Milo less and you always
drive whenever you're going a mile or
more
if you follow that rule you will
paradoxically travel two miles faster
than you travel one mile the important
Insight here is that if you only take
action when things cross a certain
threshold of Badness sometimes better
things can feel worse than worse things
look around and you'll find a lot of
people stuck in region beta the guy that
stays with his just okay job instead of
ditching it for the chance of something
better the couple who break up should
break up but can't bring themselves to
do it the friend who refuses to get a
new apartment because the current one
only has some black mold all of these
people would actually be better off if
their situations were worse because
they'd leave their jobs partners and
apartments and be glad they did their
only regret would not be leaving sooner
oh man yeah I'm getting Goosebumps man
you got to send me the link to that that
is that is epic
um I've read a um
this is kind of a funny tangent but it's
it's apropos for this I uh I read an
article I think it came out a few years
ago in the Wall Street Journal and then
the New York Times where someone
reposted it I forget exactly where it
was but it was about a guy
um I went to Harvard Business School and
he went back to his uh graduation or
sorry his reunion 20-year reunion so
he's in his early 40s and or at mid 40s
something like that middle-aged guy and
he goes back to Harvard Business School
um and you know everyone's there of
course Harvard Business School graduates
you know I worked this much fun made
this money did this thing you know
whatever and he goes look this is
anecdotal so this I'm not a scientist
this is anecdotal but what I found was
that in my classmates there was a
reverse correlation between who
graduated at the top of their class and
who was the most happy 20 years later
and he breaks it down further as to say
why and he goes the people that
graduated at the top of the Harvard
Business School class had all of these
opportunities and it was like hey here's
this 500 000 a year job that's a pathway
to the million million dollar your job
to this and that's like almost
impossible to say no to it's just like
it's too good it's like that I mean
that's what you know that that's you
made it top of her business school class
you take the top job
and he graduated in the lower 20
percentage to lower 20th percentile of
his Harvard Business School class now
granted this guy's acknowledging
privilege he's got a Harvard Business
School degree there's still a lot of
doors open to him but the big banking
Consulting the like sort of A-list jobs
were taken up by his classmates who
outranked him
and he found in this story that the
people at the bottom 20 of the class 20
years later were actually happier just
talking around they weren't divorced
they were more satisfied with their life
they had deeper fulfillment and the
question is why and it's really similar
in a different context of what you're
saying what you just shared is that they
were forced to actually for one second
think and actually choose meaning it
wasn't just laid out for them it was
like well dude you got to take the top
job because of blah blah and those
people again still with the Harvard
Business School degree so caveat there
but they had this point where like I
gotta make a choice about it it's the
guy in the black mold in his apartment
where someone's like yo you actually
have to leave this apartment you have to
go find a different way right it's not
just like the easiest next thing to
continue on the hamster wheel so whether
that hamster wheel is the Harvard
Business School Pathway to millions of
dollars at a hedge fund or you know
apply that to any sort of methodology
it's so interesting right we don't take
these inflection points and we also
hedge against that momentary discomfort
I liken it it's a funny I liken it to
you're sitting in your kitchen and you
or your spouse says I want I want a
kitchen remodel I want a new kitchen
remodel and we'd all love that you could
snap your fingers and be like new
appliances new floor new backsplash all
the fancy things that happened but we
also know that doesn't happen what
actually happens in a kitchen remodel is
you rip your kitchen apart you don't
have Plumbing you've got no stove for a
month it sucks man like it sucks meaning
you have to actually to your point about
what you just shared be less comfortable
you have to be worse off for a period of
time to actually have the better new
result with the newer kitchen Etc so
that's a silly metaphor but I think
about it so I love that seriously man
you got to send me that link dude region
beta Paradox
yes so the what you've got you've got
the zone of comfortable complacency to
me it actually seems more like a Chasm
so I think that you you end up in an
area that's very difficult to get out of
because you just move backwards and
forwards four to six four to six there's
a concept called the Overton window
which you might be familiar about which
is um the total amount of acceptable
speech that we have right so from the
worst thing to the worst thing on two
different extremes and then the Overton
window is within that what is uh
societally acceptable right typically
what's acceptable and I've been saying
for three or four years that I think
that we exist our life experience is
kind of like an Overton window and we've
brought the constraints in on the lowest
low and the highest high that we're
prepared to go to and most people go
from air-conditioned house to heated
seat car to whatever whatever and it's
exactly the same man I think that a lot
of people would do far better facing
some adversity and
it's strange to think that worse
situations can be better than better
situations sometimes and I think as well
like I asked Jocko this and I wasn't
sure whether he agreed but
I wondered whether or not perfect
childhoods can create
sub optimal adults about the fact that
not going through sufficient adversity
at some point in life can actually make
you more fragile as you grow up I don't
think that it's necessarily a hard and
fast rule I'm sure that there's people
that have amazing childhoods and grow up
to be complete Killers when they get up
but
I do think that there's a little bit of
something there and you've got this
other concept called the possible
mindset as well so how does that relate
to the zone of uh comfortable
complacency yeah no you know it it uh it
brings me back you know thinking through
my life
um I didn't grow up with a lot of
resources as a kid my parents are super
young when they had me
um but my mom definitely dared me to
dream you know kind of like hey you know
figure out how to make your way in the
world you know you can do anything you
set your mind to you know definitely a
lot of positivity but not a lot of
resources
um as a kid divorced parents certainly
had my fair share of ups and downs as a
kid
but a huge turning point in my life
um I'm 22 years old I graduate from
college and instead of getting a normal
job and again even though it's you know
I could have probably a more secure
future I decided to take a backpack and
a surfboard and you know I scraped
together a few thousand bucks from
painting houses and buy a one-way ticket
because I just want to like experience a
little bit of the world and have that
opportunity growing up
and I get out there it's a great
experience my first layover because I
had such a cheap student fair I ended up
on this like random layover and I met my
wife on that layover who I've now been
together for 15 years so I think I was a
win right out of the gate
um but uh you know hitchhike through New
Zealand slept on Floors ate peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches saved up
enough money to have a few beers at the
end of the night but it was like you
know it was it was cheap cheap you know
World Travel and I found myself
on the small island in rural Thailand
and 22 years old some guys were jumping
and flaming jump rope down the down the
street uh or down the beach and I
thought gee that looks like fun
and uh you know obviously not not the
greatest idea in the world
um and in an instant my life changed I'm
jumping the Rope the ropes sprayed with
kerosene I trip on it the excess
kerosene sprays my body lifts my lights
my body completely on fire to my neck
and I have to jump into the ocean to
extinguish the Flames but not before
about I don't know 25 of my body is
burned predominantly my legs and feet
and I'm in the middle of nowhere in
Thailand I there's no ambulance I get a
moped ride down a dirt path to a
one-room nursing station
um there's a cat running around my bed
and across my chest and this makeshift I
see I mean it's a bad bad bad set of
circumstances all around
and the worst thing about it second and
third degree burns all across my legs
and feet the doctor walks in one day
about four to five days in and he goes
hey Colin I hate to tell you this but
you'll probably never walk again
normally
um the way that your ligaments have been
burned in your ankles and your knees
you're probably gonna Never Gonna regain
full Mobility
now the it's obviously a terrible
diagnosis I've been a you know active
kid a swimmer in college Etc I think
it's a terrible diagnosis for anybody my
identity is wrapped up in being
able-bodied and physical at its young
age as a Young Man
but thankfully there's a heroine to this
story we'll get back to that possible
mindset and it really wraps around what
you're saying is my mother comes in to
Thailand she finds me on the fourth or
fifth day in the middle of freaking
rural Thailand nowhere finally finds me
and she tells me now that she was crying
with the doctors pleading in the
hallways my son I'm so afraid like how
are we going to get him out of this you
know please tell me good news but she
actually never showed me that sadness
she never showed me that fear she never
showed me her own anxiety instead she
came into my hospital room every single
day going with this huge air of
positivity being like Khan yeah you
screwed up let's not mince words you're
an idiot you should have jumped that
flaming jump rope but your life's not
over what do you want to do when you get
out of here let's set a goal look toward
the future what do you want to do and
she's again I didn't call it that at the
time but I now call it this this
possible mindset she's daring me to
drink dream with Limitless possibilities
forget about this circumstance what do
you want to do when you get out of here
close your eyes picture anything so I
closed my eyes and she sees me smile she
goes what'd you see and I said well this
might sound ridiculous but I just saw
myself crossing the finish line of a
triathlon
and she could have easily been like yeah
I said set a goal but like the legs and
the bandages and the wheelchair like I
feel like there's something
but instead she's like great you're
gonna do that in fact you should start
training right now and she yells over
she goes hey Doc hey Doc my son's
training for a triathlon
um bring him in some weight so I have
this picture of me in the Thai Hospital
bandaged from the waist down lifting
10-pound dumbbells and the doctors
looking at me like this stupid ass
American kid is never gonna walk at him
he just knock some sense into him
but it's fixed in my mind because my
mother opened my mind up again and fast
forward to this several months I'm in
the Thai hospital I get released I'm
carried on and off the plane I'm in a
wheelchair when I get home I literally
have to learn how to walk one step at a
time it's an arduous process my legs are
atropy to the size of my wrist I mean I
am I'm in a bad state but 18 months
after being burned in this fire I moved
to Chicago I take a job to Commodities
trading I sign up for the Chicago
Triathlon and I complete the race I
cross the finish line but took my
complete and utter surprise when I cross
that finish line I actually haven't just
completed the race but I actually won I
placed first out of nearly 5 000
participants on the day now
one easy moral of the story is like well
it turns out you're a superhuman freak
and you're amazing at Sports and
whatever like that's not the point of
the story where my mind went immediately
was what would have happened had my mom
not looked forced me to look towards the
future and set this measurable goal had
instilled what I call this possible
mindset inside of me right I definitely
wouldn't be sitting here with 10 World
Records I wouldn't be sitting here
talking to you I set all of those world
records with those same legs after being
burnt so your entire point about
adversity is look I wouldn't wish that
burnt accident on my worst enemy I
wouldn't but I'd also be blind to the
fact that that adversity taught me one
of life's greatest lessons something
that I can take with me through
resilience through hard times through
that calibration of going yeah that's a
one that's a one but that opened up that
doorway to the tens dude unbelievable
what was the so going from Burn to
running the triathlon what was the most
difficult part of that recovery because
this I always think about this in any
movie where the young kid in school
wants to learn MMA so that he can beat
up the bully and he can get the hot
chick and become like homecoming Prince
or whatever it's called like during that
the progression from Zero to Hero is a
montage yeah at most it's a 20 minute
sequence and maybe he gets kicked out of
the gym by the coach because he did
something wrong but that is the period
in which people make the most change
that is the bit that as far as I can see
is actually the one where that
inflection point becomes reality so talk
to me about that I'm only Laughing Man
because you're a kindred spirit bro like
my brain like I think about stuff it's
like storytelling this like I like so
many things I thought about very soon I
love it I love your Vibe
um the uh
yeah it wasn't a montage although you
could play it that way the music is
playing it's building
um
you know the hardest part honestly was
the initial
um momentum to get you know to get over
that inertia of being in that wheelchair
to be honest and it sounds silly but
it's those first couple of steps um I
remember I get back to Portland
um where I'm from Portland Oregon where
I grew up in my mother's kitchen I'm
sitting in this wheelchair and she says
to me she goes okay Colin now I know
we've even you know kind of talking [ __ ]
about this Triathlon goal in the
hospital and you know joking around the
doctors and whatever but like
today's today your goal is to actually
take your first step and she grabbed
this wooden chair from our kitchen table
and placed it one step in front of my
wheelchair and she says you need to
figure out how to get out of your
wheelchair today and take that first
step into that chair in front of you and
I remember looking down my legs are
still bandaged they're still literally
like blood the way that burns heal your
stuff like a lot of blood seeping out
and stuff like that so you got to change
the gauze all the time it's a horrible
injury to have and my legs like I said
they're like as skinny as my wrist
practically
and it took me three hours that day
literally three hours standing at the
staring at that wooden chair sitting
next to my you know wheelchair to get up
and take that first step
um you know in terms of the medical
reason why that was difficult is that
the skin was healing so tight over the
course of my ligaments and over the
course of my back my knees my ankles at
the flexibility and the mobility was
there so taking a step actually felt
like you were like ripping brand new
skin
um which is just counterintuitive to
your brain and super painful
but to me where that applies uh more
broadly than me in a wheelchair
specifically and certainly my book the
12-hour walk is really this exploration
of how we can all overcome limiting
beliefs wherever we find ourselves in
our life and our proverbial wheelchair
trying to set out on on a goal right we
set these big goals we set these big
goals you know this feeling like you uh
you uh you drink a bunch of beers with
your buddy on a Saturday night you're
like yo we're gonna train for this
marathon and we're gonna like do the
training program in the next six months
we're gonna be a fit as we've ever been
whatever and then you wake up with a
hangover and you call your buddy and
you're like yeah man like I'm out like I
I have a few too many beers last night
but like let's be honest I'm not gonna
[ __ ] run a marathon right
um what I mean by that is the momentum
like the beginning steps is where we so
often quit on ourselves because that
negative mindset as we talk about I talk
about in the 12-hour walk is limiting
beliefs they overcome you you're not
strong enough what if you fail
um you know you don't have enough money
you don't have enough time Etc when I
was walking across Antarctica my solo
crossing the first day I started crying
man I started crying because I could
barely pull my sled I had a thousand
miles to go and I couldn't even like
really cross the first quarter mile and
in my first book The Impossible first
there's a chapter it's called Frozen
tears because when you crying it's minus
30 minus 40 degrees outside Antarctica
doesn't take it easy on it just freezes
the tears to your face you feel like a
real pathetic loser in that moment and I
joke around I woke up that first day in
my tent and I'm like
I go guess who was there and people were
like wait I thought you were alone when
you're talking I'm like no no I was
alone but inside of my tent was the five
other versions of myself staring back at
me going Colin you're an idiot you just
told the New York Times you're gonna do
this thing you didn't even make it a day
you're a failure you're horrible we know
this feeling right we beat up on
ourselves in our own minds and so I
think more often than not you know the
question was about the burn accident but
again applied more broadly it's like you
can set that massive goal into some
moment of inspiration or excitement or
whatever but so often quite literally in
my case taking the first steps believing
in yourself to make incremental progress
because the summit the the triathlon
Finish Line the summit of Everest might
be a million steps quite literally
between where you are in there and
you're going these first three steps
they don't matter but they do because
they create momentum to the next steps
and the next steps and the next steps
after that how can people remind
themselves of the patience that they
need
yeah you know I I think that I always
encourage me I love to ask this question
you know what's your efforts my
childhood dream was to climb Everest and
so you know it's a framing question and
it's easy I ask it to eight nine
ten-year-olds in the School classrooms
that I do public speaking for I ask it
to adults and you know whatever in fancy
businesses you know it applies across
age groups um and demographics but it's
just a question of like let's set a big
goal like what what's what's your goal
again that possible mindset let's dream
with full purpose and passion
but then and that that's kind of the fun
part everyone's like oh one day I want
to have a million dollar I want a
private jet I want to have the thing I
want to have the credit whatever you
know people have different answers that
question I want to start the family
but then where I very quickly and again
I'm a dreamer so I love those big dreams
but I also want to ground that in
reality and I say to people I'm like
okay great you've got the Big Goal
you've got the North Star now let's get
down to real business what can you do
today today
like what can you actually do today and
again it's kind of silly but it in my
own life I literally you know dreamed
about climbing Mount Everest for my
whole life I finally Summit for the
first time in 2016. I'm up there on the
summit
and I look down and what do I see it's
obviously a bunch of ice and rocks but I
literally see a small little pebble and
I'm like huh and I reach down I pick up
the small tiny little Pebble and I put
it in my pocket and for years I carried
around my pocket with me and I carried
around as this reminder that even Mount
Everest the biggest mountain in the
world and for me my childhood dream is
actually just a bunch of tiny Pebbles a
bunch of small rocks stacked on top of
each other millions of steps leading to
the summit and so for me again I
encourage people
set the Big Goal Dare To Dream greatly
but then go to the micro micro micro
level you know what is your wheelchair
to wooden chair moment what is the one
more tiny little rock that you can stack
because you know you've talked to so
many successful people I've been
fortunate to be around many in my life
as well and what you really the through
line is a lot almost always almost
always it comes back to consistency over
time more so than this this sudden like
one-off burst of you know creativity or
something it's that burst of creativity
but it's then that action to get over
that inertia to create momentum and then
just keep chipping away stacking those
rocks dudes I had Jocko on the show a
couple of weeks ago and he said
discipline needs motivation for
breakfast you don't uh rise to the level
of your motivation you fall to the level
of your discipline and there's this
quote going back to what you just said
there about
um not wanting to wish on anybody even
your worst enemy the pain that you went
through with that stuff but also kind of
being very appreciative of it this quote
from Nietzsche and it's in the will to
power and he says to those human beings
who are of any concern to me I wish
suffering desolation sickness ill
treatment indignities I wish that they
should not remain unfamiliar with
profound self-contempt the torture of
self-mistrust the wretchedness of the
vanquished I have no pity for them
because I wish them the only thing that
can prove today whether one is worth
anything or not that one endures
um the fact that all of those things are
the difficulty and by getting through
them those are the things that prove you
on the other side
yeah I mean look I I've never heard that
quote it's great
um the uh
it's how is it is I think it's even you
know nature wrote that you know many
many many years ago and I think it's
obviously been true through human
history but I think it's actually even
more true now than it ever has been and
that's because you know again going back
you know however many thousands of years
we were hunter-gatherer Society right
there was actually things that you know
literally fight or flight you know the
saber-toothed tiger might get you you
know there was some level of having to
endure to your point right and then of
course over time we've created more and
more and more modern conveniences
um and I love my modern conveniences I
love that you and I can sit here and
have this conversation and and scale
ideas and impact
um with things like the Internet it's
like it's not to vilify that but it's
also to say we have to become more
intentionable excuse me intentional
about creating that suffering you know
even at the you know obviously there's
food insecurity in many places but even
at pretty low level of income there's
cheap accessible food at a grocery store
fast food you know Etc on a lot of
Corners so it's not like we're like
hunting and Gathering you know anymore
although our DNA is still programmed for
that kind of level of survival and when
you put on that kind of
um uh you know I guess autopilot I think
that our spirit dies a little bit and
you know for me
the 12-hour walk the book itself is
about limiting belief the book itself
brings you through all sorts of high
energy stories of row and a boat across
Drake Passage and climbing Everest and
losing friends and climbing accidents
and overcoming adversity Etc but at its
core it's a call to action for this
exact purpose for this exact quote of
what you're saying which is to say I am
inviting people to actually walk out the
front door turn their phone on airplane
mode and go for a 12-hour walk by
themselves
but it's through that lens and again
I'll double back on the origin story of
that and you know kind of why why that
methodology Etc but you know skipping
ahead for a second which is to that
point
it's not suffering like go light
yourself on fire in a beach in Thailand
you're going to learn a good lesson but
it's to that person who's living that
five that five that five that comfort
zone that and I like how you thought
about that Chasm almost this Chasm that
you can't get out of right it's to say
it's to say man like you gotta shake it
up you gotta try something different if
you stared at your phone every single
day for the last 364 days try a day
without that not because I'm telling you
not to use your phone but just take a
break move your body in a different way
try something different that implicit
your feet your legs will get tired at
the end of 12 hours your mind might get
exhausted because you're not used to
being alone in your thoughts because you
can distract yourself with dopamine hits
from your social media whenever you want
but that what Tanisha is saying right
there is to say like but that is how
you're going to learn you're going to
learn when you have that adversity that
suffering that challenge are you
familiar with um the concept of type 2
fun no okay I think you're gonna love
this
um so type one fun is uh this is not
something I made up by the way but type
one fun is like you know just the fun
dancing with your friends partying
drinking beers uh you know whatever just
fun skiing powder surfing a beautiful
wave you know whatever you do you know
that's fun just fun man that's fun
straight up
type 2 fun is when you're doing it and
mountain climbing is is a classically
type too fun but there's all sorts of
different things so it's starting a
business so you know if there's a
million things like this when you're
doing it in the moment so let's just say
you're climbing a mountain and the wind
is blowing you in the face and you're
exhausted and you're starving maybe a
little bit scared because it drops off
thousands of feet right beside you like
in the moment you're like you're looking
over at your buddy and you're like bro
like why are we doing this this is
[ __ ] man like this is terrible right
but then
a week later you're at the bar with your
buddy and you're like bro remember when
we were out on that mountain that was so
epic man we were like out there we were
living we were this like type 2 Funds
not necessarily fun when you're having
it when it's happening right but it is
epic and fun upon reflection and what I
think that is is the psyche in the
moment is kind of trying to protect you
right this animalistic instinctive to
protect yourself from this discomfort or
whatever but the payoff is in the future
you're like oh I learned something from
that oh I felt alive oh I was like
really living uh and so for me type two
fun is epic now type 3 fun is not fun
when it's happening and it's not fun to
reflect on later so that's to be
actually avoided at all costs but uh the
type two fun that's that middle ground
between just hedonistic pleasure and
actually you know the the grit and
challenge of something that is awesome
to reflect on with nostalgia
if you're going to the Antarctic who do
you need to speak to is there a is there
a gatekeeper somehow is there a person
that you need to have a chat with before
you can start walking across it
yeah so
um the short answer is yes it's uh it's
a pretty protective Place although it
it's it's always a funny conversation uh
you know I've been on Joe Rogan's
podcast a couple times and he loves to
stoke a good conspiracy theory and he's
always like so how the flutters then all
of a sudden the comments go crazy and
everything messaging me about Flat Earth
and all this stuff so as far as I know
the Earth is not flat I didn't see the
edge I didn't see any uh trenches or
whatever down there but a part of that
big uh Theory I guess from all the
people that have heckled me on the
internet about the Flat Earth
um is that it's like Antarctica is this
like place that no one can go to in it's
government controlled
um that's not entirely true of course
um however it is a very protected place
and that's what makes Antarctica amazing
it's not an autonomous region of any
country there's 12 signatory countries
um the United States being one of them
who have sort of the protecting
scientific rights of Antarctica and
that's why there's no mineral drilling
or you know anything like that
um and that actually can change in in
2041 that can change but I think that we
will renew that treaty and I hope all
the countries agree but
the the short answer is is there's this
treaty called aido which it stands for
the international Antarctic uh something
something treaty um and I forget what
all the all the letters stand for but
aido
um is basically this group of people
that you have to contact to be able to
be there
um because you can't just like go cruise
around Arctica if you're not doing the
most important things which really is
just preserving it um is is not you know
messing up the landscape it's not
changing it
um again probably two in the weeds but
when I rode a boat to Antarctica there's
even different things about the exterior
of Antarctica and the ocean part of
Antarctica because there's so much sea
life there versus the interior of
Antarctica when I walked across it's
actually a whole different but it's all
governed by Edo long story short in
terms of logistics
um and this is kind of funny is that
there basically is one guy with one plan
or I should say one company but
basically it's a one single plane of
this company called ale which governs
almost all of an expedition context of
most of the continent and so when I was
crossing Antarctica as I think you might
know I was trying to be there solo
trying to be the first but it turned out
there was another Brit uh who announced
his project about a week before I was
getting ready to depart this guy named
captain Louis Rudd this badass Special
Special Forces very experienced polar
Explorer and both of us have been
planning our Expeditions autonomously of
each other without announcing it to the
world and then I I take an interview
with the New York Times he takes an
interview with the Telegraph and they
come out on the same day and it's like
I'm gonna be the first I'm like wait
there's like another guy like this is
like a race now like and the funniest
part of it to go back to your question
about what you know the literal
Logistics of going to Antarctica of
course we both call the same one guy
with the one playing to take us to the
edge of the continent there's only one
you know weather window the Antarctic
summer that's long enough for you to be
able to do this Expedition so before we
know it I found myself on a cargo plane
shoulder to shoulder sitting next to
this special forces British badass
getting dropped off to not what I
thought my whole mind I visual that's
going to be this hard Thousand Mile
journey across Antarctica I never once
visualized it was a head-to-head mono
imano race with one of the most badass
humans I've ever met in my life and
we're dropped off on the ice like ready
go
um so anyways the the logistics make
that funny it's not it's not as if
there's all these different ways to get
there and to and from there and a
million you know it's like uh it's not
like United Airlines Delta Airlines
America you know it's not like it's not
the choices it's like a very specific
region window Logistics
um and a lot of paperwork of course just
like all these things are presumably one
of the biggest decisions that you need
to make when you're walking across is
how much you pack versus how hard it is
to pull that that part that I guess
resources to weight differential
yeah so
um no one had completed this Crossing in
the style that we were attempting to do
it which is a solo so people have
crossed Antarctica solo
um in a few different ways but not in
what's called unsupported so unsupported
is no resupplies of food or fuel people
have actually done solo unsupported but
aided aided by kites or dogs or other
things propelling them so we were doing
solo unsupported and fully human powered
by exactly to your point that
unsupported nature of that is kind of
the Crux of this which is of course
there's not a lot of infrastructure in
Antarctica but there's enough
infrastructure that you could get a
plane to drop you off a Depot of food
you know 300 miles into the journey 600
miles in the journey or uh we're both
Crossing through the South Pole and
there's a scientific research station
there an American base you know it's
only you know a small amount of people
there but you could probably arrange
some Logistics to pop inside have a
coffee you know resupply your food or
whatever and that would obviously negate
the unsupported nature of it so when I
went there there were some buildings I
hadn't seen anyone in 40 days and I just
like was like well it looks like a warm
building in there that'd be nice but
obviously you know I can't even take a
cup of coffee from a scientist who wants
to come wave to me you know to maintain
that unsupported nature of this but yeah
the math equation the math equation is
what played on people's minds of why
this may or may not have been possible I
called my project The Impossible first
and it's also named my first book
because people for a long time were like
this thing's impossible
um a long lineage of British Explorer is
actually I mean Shackleton was one of
the first people to say let's try to
cross the entire continent that's what
he was doing on the endurance Expedition
obviously they got waylaid and a whole
other Adventure ensued as we both know
from the Alfred Lansing book
um but it kind of you know had been in
the Curiosity of people's minds of the
full crossing of the continent um Henry
Worsley a very famous British Explorer
attempted The Crossing in 2015 and he
made it 71 days in only 100 miles from
the Finish Line ultimately got sick fell
ill and ultimately died super sad
another Super um renowned British
explorer who have a ton of respect for
this guy named Ben Saunders the year
before uh Captain Lou and I attempted he
was out there for 50 some days and then
ran low on food and supplies and had to
be evacuated from this and that is this
because exactly what you said which is
you'd love to have a thousand pounds of
food and Gorge yourself 10 000 calories
a day walking and trying to survive and
in temperature it's minus 40 degrees 10
000 calories a day
if you brought 10 000 calories a day for
60 70 80 Days however long you think
it's going to take you that's a thousand
pound you know that's a thousand pounds
before you know it like you're not going
anywhere on the first day you're not
gonna be able to pull your sled so I
loaded up my sled with as as much as I
possibly thought I could carry which was
375 pounds now hence the uh Frozen tears
on day one and day two because it turns
out point of 375 pound sled is at the
very limit of possibility for me as well
so much so that I called my wife on the
first day for my satellite phone I said
to her in the midst of my Tears on day
one I said well babe um I think we named
our project the right thing like this is
for sure impossible uh definitely I
can't even you know make it the first
day
but I chipped away at it but your your
question is astute which is it's this
math equation between how much you can
carry how much you can drag Etc and the
amount of time you need to be out there
um both Captain Lou and I uh lost a ton
of weight I was eating 7 000 calories
per day but I was burning ten thousand
so I'm on a 3 000 calorie deficit from
day one I know by the end my hips were
sticking out my ribs were sticking out
my body was completely beat up fully
fully fully
um declined so yeah I mean it is a a
rough situation and you know if people
wrote there's a there's a quote that I
pulled from Wired Magazine before I
started it says it is straight up
impossible to take enough calories to
cross Antarctica in in this form because
you run the spreadsheet in the math and
it's kind of like ah kilojoules in
energy output this amount of days this
amount of weight like it just doesn't
it's I mean on I mean I was on my
literal last bite of food when I made
the crossing after 54 days like I was
that was it I didn't have I didn't have
I definitely didn't have a week more in
me of food or supplies I mean I was on
the limit so I suppose as well that the
pace that you move at is also determined
by that too if you move a little bit
quicker that's going to be more hard on
your body but it also means that you
have fewer days which means less food
but it also means more energy
requirement per day because you're using
more energy to move yourself more
quickly a hundred percent and I says it
says in all seriousness I literally
didn't change my underwear for 54 days
because I didn't bring an extra pair of
anything because I wanted 100 more
calories of food in my sled was more
important to me than you know the the
nastiness of you know being in your own
same clothes for for two months but you
know that that that's a hundred percent
true of just trying to figure that out
the 12-hour walk the name the origin of
that is actually because I Lou kicked my
ass in the first first week and then I
caught up to him on uh day six of this
Antarctic expedition I I finally caught
up them and I thought I'd actually
thought I'd never see him again I
thought he was going to smoke me but I
was fortunate to catch up to him and at
that point after 10 hours is the maximal
amount of time that I can pull my site
it's just it's just the maximum amount
of time I can pull my sled there's no
way I can pull it any further
and then I catch up to Lou and we have
this like kind of funny exchange he
walks up to me and he's like all chipper
he's like hey good morning mate
um you know I've got of a bit of a
suggestion for you and I'm like this is
like a special forces train killer like
this dude's not just like being nice to
me out here like there's no freaking way
and so I said Lou I wish you know your
will we both know the stakes out here
you could die out here like whatever but
let this be the last time we speak I'm
pretty certain you're not just like
giving me like friendly chipper advice
and I remember he we all have a face
mask on right because we can't have any
Exposed Skin he lifts his face mask up
for 10 seconds it just stares me in the
eye he's just kind of like okay suit
yourself and I was like that's right
we're done talking I'll see you later
we're both carrying 300 pound sled so
it's like I'll see you later and it's
like tortoises like one step and we're
going in the same direction so we're
like right next to each other for like
an hour two hours five hours he's still
right now I mean if you saw if you're
like a video camera on both of us to be
like these two dudes are middle of
nowhere pretending like the other one's
not there they're walking shoulder for
shoulder like Marching In Like slow
motion next I will see you later it's
like saying goodbye to somebody and then
leaving out of the building in the same
direction isn't it totally it's just
awkward it's just like this is the most
awkward of awkward and so in my mind I'm
like okay
10 hours I'll make it to 10 hours he's
going to stop before then there's no way
he's going that long I don't know how
long his days are with this eight hours
goes by he's still right next to me nine
hours goes by he's still right next to
me 10 hours goes but he's still right
next to be 10 out half hours it goes by
still I'm like this guy is like
Relentless and I'm exhausted I mean I
literally am I out of my daily food
ration I'm spent for the day
11 hours goes by and he finally reaches
down and pulls his his tent out of his
sled and I'm like thank God but I don't
want to like I don't wanna I wanna
pretend I'm totally pretending that I'm
like I'm all good that I can just keep
walking forever you know it's a
psychological games and so I say to
myself I'm going one more hour so I
gained another like mile on him and I
get my first true lead in the race it's
12 hours
and then that night my wife says to me
she's like spreadsheeting all this stuff
back home like how many calories I ate
versus how many miles I'm going and like
kind of trying to solve stuff and I
talked her on my satellite phone and she
goes I've been waiting for an opportune
time to tell you this and I guess this
is the moment to tell you but unless you
start unless that 12-hour day becomes
your normal day and you don't take any
breaks like you don't take a day off
whatever like you're not even gonna come
close I'm still not sure that's gonna
get you there but I can tell you right
now 10 hours is not going to cut it so
if you thought that was hard like I need
you to repeat that 50 more times
um and honestly my limiting belief in
that moment was telling me I couldn't go
any further but I recalibrated 12 I can
do it once I could do it twice I could
do it three times and I kept that up and
honestly I've said this to Lou we both
acknowledged this I I was first and he
finished a few days behind me but we've
both acknowledged to each other two
things one
and just do the math if I had gone 10
hours instead of 12 hours over 50 some
next days that's 100 hours less that I
would have traveled I would have made it
nowhere near the finish I mean it would
have been hundreds of miles away from
finishing so because you would have run
out of food I would have run out of food
because you're gonna kind of I had a
daily ration like set up so it wasn't
like I was like it was like I would have
eaten my daily ration and then I would
have quickly realized it wasn't gonna
make it far enough but the second thing
is just kind of a an interesting human
thing about competition and how we can
in a strange way uplift each other which
is I've said to him he said to me he
goes man I don't think either of us
would have made it across had the other
one not been there which is like I never
saw him again and I actually waited for
him at the Finish Line um for a few days
but I never saw him after the day six
but every day four hours I would look
over my shoulder like he was gonna like
pop up out of nowhere like I was like
this guy's he's coming for me he's
coming for he's coming for me there'll
be a 50 60 mile per hour headwind and I
think to myself like yo this is the day
to take this off like it's minus 70
windshield like you're gonna you're
gonna get lost in this white out like
don't go out there but then I think to
myself but what if Captain Lou goes if
he goes and he passes me like you know
and so it forced me
to keep going right that competition
that intensity
um of that so
um do you think you'd have made it had
it not been for him being there as well
that's sort of my point like him being
there uplifted my game for sure it made
me it made me it forced me to
recalibrate what I thought my limits
were a hundred percent you know in this
moment
um and it made me get out of my tent on
days would have been so easy to be like
no one else is out there and no one's
like racing you think to yourself well I
could eat a little bit less food but I
could just sleep in my tent for the day
and just rest or something like that but
in the end that would have caught up
with me
um but I never took a rest day and never
took a single day off um for 54 days
straight uh pulling the sled across
there
I'm thinking about this mediator of
limiting beliefs right the story that we
tell ourselves about who we are or what
we do or what our capabilities are
it seems like
after practical restrictions like
money and the ability to not fly or
defeat gravity and the requirement to
sleep and stuff like that limiting
beliefs really are the
the main
uh rate limiting step between where you
are and you Reaching Your Potential
because there's not really anything else
in between it it's like look it's other
than genuine practical restrictions and
most of those practical restrictions
probably are filtered through your
limiting beliefs as well like I can only
do 10 hours actually no you can't you
can do 12.
limiting beliefs kind of place a glass
ceiling on a pretend glass ceiling on
what we achieve in life and it's a case
of trying to move that up so that we
have more capacity
oh 100 you know I couldn't agree more I
think it's and and the reason that in
the book and obviously people people use
that phrase limiting belief but the
reason that I use that frame you could
call it excuses you could call it doubts
there's a lot of different like words
that you can use for that but I prefer
limiting beliefs for a specific reason
which is their beliefs they're just that
they're not limiting truth these are not
limiting facts you know you named a
couple of the facts right the you know
humans can't fly you know just with
whapping their arms or something like
that but there's no those are maybe a
couple truths but the in our minds what
are holding us back these obstacles
there's beliefs and beliefs can be
reoriented Rewritten we can write a new
story of what we're telling ourselves
and that is when you step into that
possible mindset and that ultimately
through through storytelling it is what
the 12-hour walk is about what what's uh
like the kind of origin of that you know
taking that from the 12 hours of walking
in Antarctica to sort of applying the
the thought behind this book or the
origin of it is when I got to the end of
this crossing my body was beat up man I
mean beat up like I said I was skinny I
was I mean I was frail I was exhausted
but strangely through the Solitude
through the silence through the
conviction through the as Jocko says the
discipline I'm getting out of my tent no
matter what my mind got stronger I got
sharper I had more clarity than ever
before and that tapped me into
fulfillment passion curiosity creativity
I was lit up man from the inside even
though the external view of my body was
just like I mean a bag my wife was like
you know looked like I was like a drug
addict for like 10 years or something
like that like you know just like so
frail
um but anyways she I I get back from
that and I find this place in my mind of
just deep positivity and deep strength
and I think great like I have it man
I've got it I can take this with me for
the rest of my life and in in some ways
that's true
however a couple years after this
Antarctica Crossing got a bunch of big
stuff planned you know touring around my
New York Times best-selling book all
this stuff whatever boom covet hits
everything gets canceled my next
Expedition canceled my booktuber
canceled and look my you know my silly
life being canceled is a lease of the
world's problems in this moment right we
were all disrupted in this time
but also not just disrupted like there's
bad stuff happening right so I find
myself as many of us did like I'm locked
in in my house with my wife and my dog
we're on the Oregon coast in the small
cabin
and
that mindset of strength and fulfillment
and courage and positivity that I found
Antarctica was gone and that was that
was uh you know I'm doom scrolling the
news I'm getting you know every bad hit
off the internet of this and I'm
starting to worry about my grandparents
and the borders are closing and the
people like in my life that could get
this sickness and what does this all
mean right that uncertainty at that
moment obviously we know a lot more now
than we did then but March April of 2020
like it was a strange time for you know
all of humanity I think
and that wasn't that definitely I wasn't
impervious to that and I found myself
just in a downward spiral negativity
fear doubt limiting belief whatever you
want to call that my wife looks over at
me one day and she's like hey you know
you haven't changed out of your pajamas
in three days you've been sitting on the
couch it's like just literally reading a
headline headline this person died this
is happening just spinning spinning
spinning
and so I was like you know thank you for
calling my attention to that like okay I
gotta get myself out of this funk right
I was like when was the last time I felt
so tapped in like this and I was like
strangely enough it was actually when I
was walking across Antarctica silent
Stillness Solitude quiet in my mind
maybe I can get back to that so I say to
my wife I say to Jenna I say look hey uh
I'm gonna go for a long walk tomorrow
Alone
um you know one of the few things you
could do during a lockdown is just be
outside alone for a period of time uh
depending on where you were in the world
and I said don't worry don't worry I'll
probably back around dinner I don't know
12 hours something like that like I used
to walk she's like okay have fun so I
walk out my front door
20 minutes in my phone Buzz is in my
pocket and I reach my phone
instinctively I look down you know my
buddy's texting me I'm gonna text him
back and I'm like what am I doing like
I'm just like out here on this block I'm
gonna stare at my phone texting my buddy
and like what I'm gonna get on Zoom call
next like hold on a second like you
don't need this just today so I put my
phone on airplane mode and I keep
walking 12 hours I take breaks I rest
but I'm out there for 12 hours alone in
the Stillness and silence no music no
podcast nothing
and I get back to my front door 12 hours
later my dog jumps up on me and my wife
looks over at me and she goes you're
back
and I'm like yeah I told you I was going
to come back around dinner time whatever
she goes no no no you're back you're
back like she could just see it in my
spirit that I was back and I was like
yeah I feel better than I felt in a long
time really needed that now I thought
look I'm the guy who walked across
Antarctica walked around solos done all
these like whatever epic endurance
challenges blah blah blah maybe that's
just a me thing but during covet all
sorts of friends of mine would call me
you know family members colleagues Etc
and be like yo I'm struggling with this
I'm trapped in my house I'm stuck in my
uh you know my like my job just I got
lost my job at this I that I started
just suggesting this 12-hour watch
people this might sound crazy but take
the 12-hour walk and that can look like
anything you know young people old
people fit people not so fit people I
said the walk is 12 hours in silence
take as many breaks as you want I don't
care if you go for one mile for 50 miles
my 77 year old mother-in-law she did her
walk by walking one time around her
block and then sitting on her porch for
an hour and then walking another time
around the block but she maintained the
silence and Solitude training her mind
throughout this entire 12 hours
and again we talked about this a little
bit but it's it is a little bit it's
challenging it's outside your comfort
zone it forces you to do something
different but what I have found is that
despite maybe hour five your legs get
tired hour seven your mind's exhausted
like I wish I could have a podcast to
distract me don't get me wrong I love a
good podcast that I usually listen to
music podcasts Etc but taking that one
day that's just to shake that up that
difference
every person I have known to get back to
their front door after that 12-hour walk
is lit up they're refreshed they're
rebooted they have more creativity more
curiosity they've been working on this
problem in their own life and they
uncover It Whatever limiting beliefs are
coming up for them they're battling back
through them and in fact the 12-hour
walk I always say it starts right now in
this moment because if you're listening
to this podcast you're hearing this for
the first time what ends up happening is
you're either this Colin O'Brady guy man
this guy's full of [ __ ] I'm never gonna
do this Vlog this is stupid whatever the
point being oh I say that it starts
right now is that the 12-hour walk of
course when you pick that date you put
it on your calendar you take the walk
that's the experience but right now
you're bargaining with yourself and your
mind you can't help it by listening to
this right now something is coming up in
your mind and either going yeah I'm
going to do that or I'd love to do that
but I don't have enough time I don't
have enough money what if I fail my feet
are going to be hurt I'm gonna do this
and here's the thing whatever limiting
beliefs if they're coming up for you and
you're hearing this for the first time
I'm holding up a mirror to you because
these actually are the same limiting
beliefs I'm certain that are looping on
your brain dozens and dozens and dozens
of time that are actually as you said
Chris putting the glass ceiling on your
own hopes and your dreams and beliefs
but here's the thing the invitation for
the 12-hour walk that anyone can do on
any day is for you to actually say to
your limiting beliefs your own interior
dialogue oh I don't have enough time I'm
gonna make the time and then you do the
12-hour walk and then that limiting
belief comes up for you a week later you
go oh hello limited belief I see you
there but I remember last time I pushed
that aside I can overcome that I can
prove that I can actually optimize my
time or I'm willing to seek a little bit
of discomfort to get those tens and
that's really the the Beauty and the
juice and for me man I'm so excited
about this book but more than anything
I'm excited about just sharing this
methodology that is free accessible to
every single person because the ripple
effect in people's lives and that
positivity you know that's the world I
want to live in I want to live in a
world where people are lit up up not not
surrounded by the massive men leading
lives of quiet desperation but the mass
of men and women who are lit up to take
on life and to Summit the Everest
whatever that Everest looks like for
them in their own lives dude let's
[ __ ] go I love it it's so so good
am I right thinking that you've made an
app as well and is there a day that
people are supposed to you can do it
with if you want to do it with a bunch
of other people around the world yeah
yeah yeah so um those are all true it's
funny I did make an app it's funny I'm
saying turn off your phone put on
airplane mode but I built an app for you
um I did build that because here's the
thing people started going like well if
I put my phone on airplane mode I'm not
gonna be able to look at maps and I'm
gonna get lost and I'm afraid I'm not
gonna be able to find my way back home
whatever I said great I built you an app
and it does two things it puts your
phone into airplane mode so you got that
covered no no app no no text no other
than this stuff but the GPS tracks you
GPS as some people know and don't know
actually can track you with your phone
in airplane mode so it draws a line you
can see where you've been it's basically
Google Maps you can scroll in and out
inside the 12-hour walk app and then the
other thing it does is it's a clock man
it counts down from 12 hours so you can
look down and say okay I've been seven
miles I got five hours left to go
whatever that is so I basically taken
care of the two things that I think you
you need your phone for and I tell
people put your phone in your pocket on
airplane mode but have it with you for
safety of course and there's a lot of
eqs on the website 12-hour walk you can
sign up any single day to do the walk
obviously read the book the book is kind
of an essential companion that is not
just a dense textbook about walking it
it'll light you up about all sorts of
stories that I think you'll really enjoy
about how we can all conquer our minds
but on the website you can sign up you
pick a day because here's the thing you
and I both know this Chris actually
picking a day putting it in your
calendar committing to something is a
lot different than saying hey I'm going
to do this thing one day one one day
becomes next year next two years you
just can kick that down the can so it's
free I don't get a dollar for every
person doing the walk but I'm asking you
to commit because I'm your
accountability partner I'm gonna send
you emails and say remember okay you're
a week out you're five days out here's a
few tips and tricks Etc so come and sign
up and then to take that one step
further again this is Evergreen do it on
any day that you wish but on September
10th of this year I'm fighting Global
Mass participation which is to say
you're doing it by yourself you're doing
it at your front door and just a note
ambient city noise out your front door
if you're in Manhattan or you're in
Austin whatever that doesn't negate your
silence your silence is your own if cars
are driving past people walking past you
on the street totally fine uh your
silence is your own commitment to you
know maintaining your Solitude and your
own own brain
um but uh on September 10th I'm gonna do
the walk with all sorts of people doing
the what Chris I'll love for you to join
the walk on that day if you're up for it
um but basically it's to say we're doing
this alone together and we're going to
do some meetups and some Zoom calls and
some Integrations of that with that
community of people that are picking
that day but it's just to say if you
need that accountability but if you also
need accountability there's a million
other ways or you're listening to this
and it's after September 10th is to say
look you got that group text in your you
know pocket with your five college
buddies like hit them all up pick a day
just put it on your calendar your mother
your sister your best friend pick a
couple people you're all doing it by
yourself but you have that
accountability we picked this day okay
it's 6 a.m you on your front porch yeah
man I'm on my front porch you about to
start the walk yeah I'm about to start
my walk all right phone on airplane mode
see you in 12 hours maybe you meet up
for dinner that night and talk about
your experience so it's just the power
of collective accountability ultimately
the the 12-hour walk is to be done alone
but to be in participation of community
of community of like-minded people that
are trying to cultivate a possible
mindset trying to unlock their best life
um and so it's not a call to action to
become a Hermit and sleep in the cave by
yourself self afterwards it's a call to
action to say take a deep dive in your
mind because you're going to be a better
friend a better Community person a
better colleague more lit up throughout
your life and then to integrate that uh
in community so sign up any day
September 10th I'll be doing it with you
so if that works for you put that on
your calendar check out the book
um uh I know you're gonna love it
dude I [ __ ] love your energy it's so
good so inspiring uh what's the website
that people should go to where can I get
the app when's the book out
books out on August 2nd uh so I don't
know when this is coming out but it's
coming out just a few days uh probably
out by the time this goes live pick up
the book
um the website is 12hourwalk.com so
everything you need is there also inside
the book
um are a number of QR codes that
actually bring you to archival video
content from the story so I tell you a
story about row and a boat across Drake
Passage I'm lighting you up with words
and then it's like oh you want to
actually see a video of me getting my
ass kicked in the middle of the ocean
well scan this QR code and check it out
so there's a whole sort of interactive
component to all that the app also
should be live in both the App Store and
Google play
um right around the time of book
launches the last last little tweaks are
making to it but uh it's ready to go and
excited to you know have everyone
participate in the walk uh come join the
movement
um and come say hello to me on social as
well I'm at Colin O'Brady pretty active
on Instagram so uh come say hello share
your story with me and uh can't wait to
see out there on the walk Colin I
appreciate the [ __ ] out of you man thank
you what's happening people thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace